[Música]
ao longo da minha carreira gente eu
conheci reis na nigéria
tive conversas muito legais com
diretores do banco mundial foi a fórum
na assembleia geral da onu e foi
finalista do prêmio de sustentabilidade
muito legal também lá no vale do silício
mas onde eu aprendi mesmo sobre
tecnologia de impacto foi pingando folha
decoramos no meu olho com uma
conjuntivite sinistro na beira do rio
negro ao tomazoni foi batendo o carro de
frente numa estrada de chão no ceará e
foi visitando milhares de grupos de
fazendeiros e pequenos agricultores não
em vários países da áfrica
eu acredito muito que tecnologia é um
processo social e deve ser enxergado
assim se a gente quiser realmente
resolver os problemas mais críticos da
sociedade mas nem sempre tive esse olhar
para os processos era muito determinista
quando eu tinha a idade da maioria de
vocês
achava que ia ser efetivado no estágio
na multinacional que até agora com a
namorada da época que eu ia fazer
mestrado doutorado é tudo certinho ainda
estava nessa nessa pilha essa vontade
quando comecei a aprender junto a um
cara muito legal que fazia parte de uma
grande rede de empreendedores sociais é
uma rede global muito muito forte mesmo
e um negócio onde uma microdestilaria de
etanol inovadora era o centro de um
conceito de desenvolvimento rural e
acesso à energia é muito louco
empreender muito legal e principalmente
com tecnologia para o impacto social
foram muitos aprendizados a gente foi
coisa muito legal foi a países incríveis
que normalmente não se vai no comércio
internacional brasileiro mas a gente
fechou depois de cinco anos decidiu
descontinuar as atividades da empresa
foram muitos aprendizados aí gente
primeiro a levar nossa solução
tecnológica para esses com o seu para
esses contextos
e tentar fazer com que vários atores
diferentes se junta em torno dela pra
que aí funciona o conceito de
desenvolvimento rural de acesso à
energia de cozimento limpo dos alimentos
é muito difícil a gente botou o pé no
barro mas não faltou botar o pé no barro
entendendo quais eram as reais
necessidades das pessoas que moravam
naqueles lugares e principalmente dos
desejos dos atores não agregar
organizações e pessoas em volta dos
nossos interesses mas construir seus
interesses e assim ter desdobramentos no
desenvolvimento tecnológico é eu estava
então querendo viver resultado surpresa
de planos antigos que planos eram esses
eram coisas que estavam incomodando eu
queria seguir nós tico queria ter mais
de uma resposta para problemas sendo que
a mesma solução via vários problemas e
sempre tocando o mesmo conceito às vezes
empreender tem disso te cega
até que fui convidado para empreenderem
wtt que é uma fundação que promove
tecnologias de impacto social
e aí foi maravilhoso porque o convite
que eles fizeram foi justamente o dia de
ver esse sonho de fazer pontes entre
desenvolvedores de tecnologia
financiadores organizações
internacionais e comunidades mas com um
espaço muito grande pra ter empatia
junto a essas comunidades para poder
viver na pele as dores que as
comunidades vivem e assim conseguir
influenciar e tocar esse processo social
que têm desdobramentos do
desenvolvimento das tecnologias
a gente faz aquilo de várias formas a
gente vai com tecnologia super
transformativas que ainda estão dentro
da academia ou startup a gente fala com
a indústria tradicional ou a gente
mobiliza organizações que estão perto de
onde esses problemas acontecem no dia a
dia onde tem esses desafios sociais mais
críticos mesmo e com que eu tenho me
dedicado mais tempo ultimamente são os
desafios de impacto que diz respeito
mais essa última parte como a gente
entende
quais são os desafios mais críticos que
requerem desenvolvimento tecnológico e
cria espaços de inovação dentro da
realidade das organizações que estão em
campo e das comunidades para resolver
seus desafios né
os desafios vêm então de basicamente de
duas visões
a primeira é de que a academia startup
100 indústrias tradicionais fazem
desenvolvimento tecnológico de
excelência pesquisa também de excelência
a nível mundial mas que na maioria dos
casos desconhecem as realidades da base
da pirâmide e de onde estão esses
contextos críticos
por outro lado a gente entende que
organizações de campo que trabalha com
as comunidades têm muita vontade de
inovar conhece em profundidade os
problemas mas não tem capacidade de
buscar essas tecnologias avaliar elas e
principalmente recursos então o desafio
de impacto se propõe a fazer essa ponte
mas com uma metodologia bem básica
a primeira é de articular parceiros em
torno de um tema ou de um território que
queiram têm um cada um seu interesse
convergente em relação a um desafio
específico
a segunda é realizar um diagnóstico bem
profundo sobre quais são esses desafios
e priorizar eles depois da chamada
pública é um espaço de democratização de
busca de soluções a gente amplia então a
visão dos atores que estão naquela
articulação pra buscar soluções com o -
de preconceito possível e por fim o
coração dessa metodologia que é pilotar
soluções é levar a campo é sentir qual é
o processo social que se desenvolve no
campo
a primeira iniciativa que a gente tocou
já com com bastante sucesso em relação a
essa metodologia água mais nuno que no
que diz respeito a essa articulação dos
parceiros
a gente tá com o instituto coca-cola
fundação avina e organizações que fazem
a gestão comunitária da água em várias
comunidades espalhadas pelo brasil
principalmente no norte e nordeste né
e quer resolver esse problema gigantesco
são 35 milhões de pessoas sem água no
brasil o modelo de gestão comunitária
ele se mostra muito sucesso porque são
as comunidades fazendo a gerência dos
seus próprios sistemas de abastecimento
de água
isso é importante porque a cada 1 dólar
que se investe em água e saneamento se
gera uma economia de 5 46 dólares
dependendo da fonte pode ser a
organização mundial de saúde banco
mundial
gates foundation e outro dado que é
muito importante é que entre dois e
cinco anos é o que demora para um
projecto de águas e saneamento virar
elefante branco na américa latina toda
grana que se bota em projetos de água e
saneamento que foca uma infraestrutura
às vezes na adequada ou que não está
conectada com o modelo de gestão que vai
tocar essa tecnologia depois que ela for
instalada
vira lixo sucata entre dois e cinco anos
a américa latina então por isso que
esses parceiros se juntaram para
justamente fazer é aplicar esse modelo
de inovação articulação entre parceiros
diferentes focado no acesso á a gente
realizou então o diagnóstico em quatro
estados
encontrou nove desafios que vão desde
dureza na água até acesso e tratamento
em comunidades isoladas como acontece
muito na amazônia
a gente teve 120 boas inscrições
encontrou seis soluções que muito
interessantes de ir a campo e quatro
fora do eixo tradicional de ciência e
tecnologia no brasil porque eu acho
muito importante aqui porque um dos
valores principais inovação é
diversidade e quando se fala de
tecnologia de impacto
isso é muito mais importante ainda
porque geralmente onde estão esses
desafios é onde a gente encontra grande
parte dessa diversidade que não está nos
grandes centros como exemplo disso eu
trouxe dados de um livro que eu gosto
muito que fala desses pontos cegos de
inovação que se chama the novel push by
the spot do rosberg ele fala aqui da
realidade americana mas acho que a gente
pode fazer um
bem facilmente com o que acontece no
brasil 80% do investimento que vai
prestar tanto que é na economia
tradicional o principal motor de
inovação vai só para três estados nos
estados unidos esses 80% são 50 por
cento metade do investimento mundial em
star táxi mas só para três estados nos
estados unidos 7 por cento só vai para
mulheres brancas e um por cento vai pra
fundadores negros latinos além de todo o
problema estrutural do preconceito das
raízes históricas da complexidade por
trás disso
o que eu quero ressaltar que enquanto de
inovação a gente está perdendo por causa
desses olhares limitados
quantos quantas pessoas sofrem na pele
no dia a dia de problemas poderiam ser
resolvidos com tecnologias ou com outras
soluções de negócios por causa disso um
exemplo que eu ia trazer aqui a gente
pilotou é justamente de uma ponte
acontecendo e que é importante a campo
porque esse processo que eu escrevi lhe
parece muito simples né
parece uma coisa aí todo mundo faz mas
via campo onde acontece as coisas onde a
verdade se mostra o ozônio é um
desinfetante natural mais potente é um
bom anti oxidante e funciona na
prefeitura para tratar com a prefeitura
de paris em shopping centers em hotéis
mas na comunidade de 100 famílias lá do
céu em coqueiro no ceará porque ele não
pode ter acesso a uma tecnologia que
caiba na realidade dele e que deu acesso
à água pra ele pra todas essas famílias
então a gente levou esse piloto de
ozônio ou a enfrentamos muitos problemas
desde a da fase de desenvolvimento
tecnológico aplicado para esse contexto
específico até fazer o projeto executivo
para pensar como casar e campo que é
onde tudo acontece antes tinham levado o
gasto de energia por causa da
necessidade de bombas e reatores como
resolveu notando isso se criou um reator
vertical que usa a força da gravidade
economizando investimento inicial
no custo de energia mesmo que agora ele
tomou água tratada deles lá por causa
dessa tecnologia é muito simples e mas
tudo acontece em campo
dessas relações então o convite que eu
queria pra você fazer pra vocês é que
saiam do coworking salas laboratórios
vão botar o pé no barro
as tecnologias que vão resolver os
problemas que existem agora que afetam
milhões de pessoas no mundo só vão ser
desenvolvidas se a partir de co criação
dessas tecnologias e pra isso a gente
tem que abraçar a diversidade viveram
intensamente amar essa diferença e
navegar nas incoerências
vamos pôr bar ligado
[Aplausos]